Take a look at the t-shirt you're wearing or your jeans,
or even the money you have in your pocket. I'm Scottish.
So I don't have any to show you, unfortunately,
but all those things are made of cotton. Yeah. The dollars and Euro bells too.
Well,
I have some bad news to tell you one in five of you maybe wearing a product made
by slave labor, right?
Unfortunately as pure mathematics,
a quarter of all the cotton in the world is produced in China. Within China.
88% of the cotton crops are grown in the yang Jang region.
And if you're a regular follower, visual politic,
you'll be aware of what is happening right now.
And yang discrimination against the younger people,
reeducation camps and forced labor. Okay. Back to the myth,
if a quarter of the world's cotton is produced in China and off this cotton,
88% comes from Jinjiang.
We only have to make the rule of three to find out what percentage of cotton is
produced in this region where the wheat or minority is practically enslaved by
the Chinese.
You don't even have to get out your calculator because I'm going to tell you
it's 22%. Yeah, that's right. 22%,
or just over a fifth of all the world's cotton that we all like so much is the
product of forced labor. And it's used by big brands like H and M Adidas, Ikea,
a Nike. And in case anyone thinks it's not a big deal brace yourselves,
because this is not the worst thing.
China is not the only country that is covering up human rights abuses in cotton
production.
And although it may be hard to believe there is something even worse than forced
labor.
Check this out.
Nimble fingers. Myth is particularly relevant to cotton seed production,
where employers claim that tasks of cross-pollination emasculation and hand
pollination are best undertaken by prepubescent female children as is the case
in India, ILO international labor organization.
Yup. That's right. And the 21st century,
there are still producers who publicly argued the benefits of child labor.
Unless we clear, we are not talking about teenagers,
but about children who start work from the age of five,
They're also very often employed to pet cotton because compared to adult
pickers, they have two advantages. One is that because children are shorter,
they don't have to bend down to pick up the cotton.
And two is that they can be paid much, much less than any adult.
So if you are an unscrupulous business person with no government control,
the best thing you can do in your cotton field is to enslave an entire
school. And I was seeing that as a joke,
but there are countries that do exactly that when the fall comes,
they take students out of the classroom to go and pick cotton.
[Inaudible].
And you're probably thinking, so in this video,
we're going to talk about terrible things, right?
Like modern slavery and child labor. Because if we are grunt,
I need to go make myself a cup of tea.
And this is going to be one of those ones.
But the truth is that we are not because in the midst of this very bleak
situation, we actually have some good news,
forced and child labor in Uzbek, cotton fields continues to fall ill. So names.
So what's the point. If you remember, and a visual politics,
which we talked about as Becca, Stan,
we said the country was won by a wild object dictatorship,
and that it had no scruples about enslaving its population to pick cotton.
And in case anyone was wondering the same dictator who ruled Ben is ruling.
We are talking about Mr. Chef Kat mere soil yet,
and I may have gotten that name wrong, but he's a dictator. So who cares?
No expect nothing has changed.
The Uzbeks continued to suffer under a regime that considers human rights to be
at best optional. And you may ask then,
how is it possible that all of a sudden this dictates or has had an attack of
conscience and he's going to end both forced and child labor.
Has he been visited like Scrooge by three Dickensian ghosts and realized that he
has to change his ways? Well, not exactly.
So why has this Pakistan decided to eliminate forced and child labor?
How is it doing it?
And to what extent can it serve as a model for other cotton producing countries
today, we are going to answer all these questions.
And before we take a look at some history,
I just want to tell you about our new channel visual Academy from the coast,
the Spanish penetrated,
and began to it's covering all the most interesting people,
places and periods in history with some great animation.
And I can only assume a very handsome sighting voiceover. Yeah, yeah.
That man's name was Gingiss. Can you check out? No,
let's get cracking
it's everywhere. It may surprise you. But cotton is one of the 10,
most widely planted crops in the world behind wheat, corn, race soybeans,
and some serious arrives.
2.6% of all cultivated land on the planet is planted in cotton.
That's about the same surface area as Germany pull it.
Furthermore, as you know, unlike wheat or corn, cotton is not eaten,
but even so occupies twice as much land. As for example, potato fields,
what's more up to 300 million.
People are almost 3% of the world's population worked at some stage of the
cotton production chain. And you're probably thinking,
why do we need to plant so much cotton?
If in principle it's only used for clothing and not all blues,
because there are also clothes that are made of linen or hemp or a myriad of
other fabrics, then that might be true,
but it turns out the cotton is used for pretty much everything. Enlightened.
Look, this five-year old bill is actually pure cotton. Think about it.
If the bills were made of paper,
it would be impossible for them to last very long to withstand getting dumped,
not to mention the occasional spin in the washing machine. On the other hand,
if they are made with cotton fiber, they are more robust, flexible,
and resistant,
but that's not all cotton is also used in a multitude of objects that we use in
our daily lives, home textiles, coffee filters, shoelaces,
and it's even component of some flat screen TVs.
The seeds and oil is extracted as used in the production of soaps Margery,
and some plastics, cotton is even used in spacesuits.
And here's a fun fact.
In 2019 trainer tried to plant cotton on the far side of the moon.
The importance of cotton in our lives is easier to understand why there are so
many countries that grew cotton. There are at least 90 of them,
practically half of the world, the main producers are India, China,
and the United States and uncle Sam exports.
The most cotton to the rest of the world for its part.
The European union is pretty far behind.
The only cotton grown here is in Spain and Greece and production does not come
close to that of other continents.
But today we are going to focus on a different region.
One where cotton is so important and relative terrors,
they are one of the largest producers of this white gold per square kilometer
and pear inhabitants.
We are talking about countries that are so dependent on cotton cultivation.
They've even drawn the plant on their national coat of arms.
And they also have quite favorable climatic conditions for producing wine.
Cool.
We're talking about central Asia or as we know it is Pakistan Turkmenistan,
Tajikistan Kurt's extend Kazakhstan, Pakistan and Afghanistan. You know,
the stems
Bottom has a very curious property because it is a plant that does not tolerate
frost and needs a warm climate,
but without exceeding 35 degrees Celsius and addition,
the ideal environment is one where there is little moisture because during the
process of harvesting the cotton, it has to be drained. But at the same time,
the plant itself needs a lot of water. For example,
to plant 200 grams of cotton, which is what is used to make,
let's say this t-shirt 2000 liters of water are needed of all the water used
in agricultural work. 3.5% goes exclusively to the production of cotton.
So tonight, if you look on a map for a place that is warm,
but not too hot without frost with a moderately dry climate,
but it still has a lot of water.
The truth is that you will find that there are quite a few areas with optimal
conditions for growing cotton. These days,
73% of the world's cotton is produced thanks to irrigation systems.
And that means if you grew a lot of cotton, you use up a lot.
And I mean a lot of water so much that there are regions that are losing their
rivers and lakes because of the massive production of white gold.
Remember this because in a few minutes,
I'm going to tell you about the biggest water tragedy ever caused by color.
[Inaudible].
Set up. We are not only talking about ecological disasters,
but also humanitarian wounds because there are countries where cotton is
harvested by slave labor or even children.
[Inaudible].
What's worse. It is very difficult.
Know if the t-shirt you are wearing right now is one of the garments made by
forced labor because the cotton supply chain is one of the most complex and the
world. I mean, this one could be made by slave labor.
No, I'm going to tell you the story of a dirty slave labor made cotton.
T-shirt like, I've never worn first. A seed is planted. And one of those fields,
we talked about warm, dry, and with a lot of water, a few months later,
someone has to pick off the typical cotton balls and take them to a ginning
factory where the Lindt is separated from the seat and any kind of impurities,
the cotton lint, which is used in the textile industry,
travels to another place,
whereas washed and pass through a press to become a block of cotton,
which is also called.
Weirdly a cake. This.
Goes to the next stage of production,
where transformed into a yarn then comes the weaving or knit process in which
this yarn becomes a fabric. And finally someone will make our t-shirts,
which can then go on display.
And one of the windows of the major fashion brands,
Everything I have told you could happen in one country,
but the truth is that this is not often the case.
The most common story is that the cotton is picked in country,
a transformed into a fabric and country B made up in country C and finally
sold in country.
D we are talking about a super traditional sector with a very long production
chain and a lot of hands through which the cotton weaves its way before becoming
a team. Therefore, at the end of the day,
it was very difficult to know who produces the raw cotton used to make,
for example, Zara's t-shirts and I know what you're wondering right now,
if cotton is in such high demand, why isn't it pecked by machines?
It may surprise you,
but agriculture is one of the sectors that has changed the most in the last
century. Nowadays, almost nobody harvests wheat by hand harvesting machines.
They do it. So why in the case of cotton, are children still being used? Well,
let's take a look at that.
Right now,
the Soviet.
Crap. Normally, when we talk about the great empires of the world,
we think of the British, the French, the Spanish colonizers,
maybe even the Americans, but not the Russian empire,
because most of us take it for granted that the Russian empire is so big because
well, Russia is of it's as simple as that, right?
I think maybe when the countries of the world were dividing up all the lens of
the planet, Russia said, you give me two, but instead through the joker,
but the truth is no. In fact,
the great Russian empire expanded very slowly and only became great as
such in the 18th century. When they took over all of Siberia,
they continue to expand in the South until they reached central Asia.
And that's where they found the perfect place to plant corn.
[Inaudible].
Warm, dry climate with several rivers to boots. So what's the problem.
The problem was that for some reason, they didn't trust the entire population.
They had just forcibly annexed, you know,
colonizer stuff besides like all good colonizers.
They thought they were the superior.
And that's why all the production was always in the hands of Russian
businessmen. Now we jump ahead to October, 1917. What happened on this date?
Exactly goodbye, Russian empire, hello,
union of Soviet socialist republics. At that point,
the communist party said, no, we are all a brotherhood.
We are all comrades today for you to borrow for me.
So central Asian republics keep planting cotton as if they will know tomorrow.
And in return, the rest of the USSR will see to it that you will lack nothing.
And that helps to explain why it was Pakistan produced two thirds of all the
cotton in the Soviet union.
[Inaudible].
So you're probably thinking though, well, that's good, right? I mean,
what's wrong with, is Pakistan producing a lot of cotton? Well, believe me,
it is a problem. You remember that growing cotton requires a lot of water,
right? And I mean, a lot of water, well is Pakistan is a desert country.
So where did he get all the water? The answer is in the ROC.
If I asked you to point it out on a map,
you had better be pretty quick because it has practically disappeared.
That's right. The RLC is one of the largest lakes in the world.
Or rather we should say at once, check this out.
You're talking about one of the largest salt lakes in the world,
on the border between Uzbekistan and Kazakhstan,
which in turn was fed by several rivers. Well,
what the communist party did was to say, well, let's see here.
Do we have the fourth largest Lake in the world with a lot of aquatic life and
totally dependent on two rivers,
we can divert the water from these rivers to the cotton plantations and see what
happens. As you can imagine. When the two rivers stopped filling the ROC,
it began to gradually shrink. And at the same time,
keep in mind that as the Soviet union was the communist country, par excellence,
all production, including cotton plantations was in the hands of.
The state.
What does this mean? Well,
those who worked in these fields did not own the land.
They did not keep the cotton, the pecs,
and they had to meet very high delivery quarters for cotton.
But on the other hand,
the field was not their property and they could stop managing it at any point
that the committee on duty told them to in conclusion,
they had no incentive to invest in machinery.
And I know what you're going to tell me.
Now it's been almost 30 years since the fall of the Soviet union. In fact,
it was, Pakistan is no longer a Soviet Republic,
but it's own independent country. And yes you are. Right.
But as far as ownership of the countryside is concerned,
the system remains virtually and tucked.
And now I know what you thinking in the 1990s,
both is Pakistan and to GICA Stan became independent and yes, you're right,
but their economies were designed to export a single product.
Cotton.
Think about it. If depending on oil is problematic,
a commodity in which has much more demand. And for your producers,
imagine what happens if your nation is dependent on cotton from one day to the
next,
it was Pakistan was competing face-to-face with the United States and China.
They had no technology and no industry, the produced. Anything else,
no matter that the countries of central became independent from the Soviet union
land ownership remained in the hands of the state.
Listen up.
The land it's minerals, waters, flora, and fauna.
Other natural resources shall constitute the national wealth and shall be
rationally used and protected by the state article 55 constitution of
Uzbekistan land it's end trails,
water airspace, flora, and fauna,
and other natural resources shall be owned by the state and the state guaranteed
their effective use in the interest of the people.
Article 13 constitution of Tajikistan.
That's right. And these countries, the very earth itself belongs to the state.
That means that you may be lucky enough to be given a farm,
but in return you will have to plant what the state tells you. So once again,
it doesn't pay for farmers to make large investments in machinery,
but that's not the only reason that harvesting is mechanized.
Even if it's less efficient, handpick,
cotton pays much better because it's better quality. Just to give you an idea.
A kilo of picked cotton pays 16 cents more than machine picked cotton.
In other words, both of the United States and Europe machine harvest cotton,
and can therefore offer more competitive prices than is Pakistan and the other
central Asian countries.
The only way these countries can compete is in the niche market of handpicked
cotton. Mostly because there are very few producers of this type.
If we also keep in mind that these producers tend to be wilds dictatorships,
we find ourselves with barbarities.
Yes.
Because Pakistan has second highest prevalence of modern slavery in the world,
Euro Asia net.
Every year up to 2 million people worked on Uzbek,
cotton plantations against their wealth. And that included children,
basically September came and instead of getting out of their new textbooks,
students and their teachers would take a bus, go to a cotton plantation.
[Inaudible].
May seem incredible to you,
but this has been the reality and is Pakistan until just a couple of years ago,
when this came out in the international media,
you do spec government tried to backpedal a little bit and banned child labors
in the cotton fields, but they didn't do it quite right.
Although the children's stopped working on the plantations,
their teachers still spent September, October, and November picking cotton.
So what the outcome is Beck children couldn't go to school.
So now the burning question is,
so what has happened more recently to change this situation?
Why has this Pakistan banned slavery almost overnight? Well,
that is what we're going to look at right now.
The market decides mate, look.
The label on your possibly dirty slave made t-shirt you degenerate.
I would never wear such a thing. I'm sure it doesn't say maiden is Pakistan.
It probably says something like made in Turkey or made in Bangladesh.
And you'll say, what, why are they lying to us as is always the case?
The answer is
For the cotton production gene. We talked about before,
which is one of the longest and most complex in the, and what have I told you?
But the country that imports the most cotton from countries like Afghanistan to
Pakistan and his Pakistan.
Is Turkey.
Turkey.
Turkey is one of those countries where companies like Nike or H and M have their
textile factories. Now it should begin to make sense. Indeed.
Turkey is one of the largest cotton hubs in Europe ever seen as a raw material
from central Asia and converts it into clothing or sends fabric to large textile
factories.
Other countries.
It's impossible to trace where the cotton and your t-shirt comes from. However,
I'm sure none of you would buy a t-shirt knowing that slave labor has been
involved. I certainly would. Of course,
there's already a huge debate around companies outsourcing to countries with
cheap labor, but no one absolutely movement defends the use of slavery.
And some will think the multinationals don't care about it and slipping anyone
if it means making money. And though sometimes that's true.
Consumers don't think the same way.
And neither does NGOs nor most importantly the courts.
So what is the solution? Well, on the one hand quality signals right now,
there are a lot of agencies that oversee cotton production and only quit.
The seal on finished items,
have no children or slaves have been involved in production.
And that explains news.
Like this.
Pakistan over 100 companies as shoe who's, Beck, cotton, Euro Asia net.
Wait, this is what happened in 2012,
suddenly it was Pakistan lost almost all of its buyers.
We're not just talking about companies here. We're talking about governments.
You lawmakers block textile deal with who's Becca Stan,
over child labor concerns, R F E R L.
Certainly it was Pakistan became the Golem of countries,
small despised and obsessed with its precious cotton. But not only that,
it was done needed to reduce its dependence on cotton. For example,
they needed to start growing wheat. So they wouldn't have to import it.
On the other hand, if they wanted to continue selling cotton,
they had no choice, but to leave slavery behind.
And that explains why since 2012, the country has been reforming its policies.
First, they stopped forcing children to grow and pick cotton.
Then they stopped and sleeping officials.
And we're not just talking about a superficial change here,
according to the international labor organization,
which is not exactly friendly to the Islamic government,
94% of the people who were picking cotton in 2019 did so
voluntarily. Of course, that still means there is 6% of slave labor.
But remember that we're talking about changing a system that has sustained the
entire national economy for decades. And now, uh,
nor you're thinking about what we were thinking about,
what you thought before is Pakistan has no technology and no,
they have no sleeves. How can they be competitive in the marketplace?
The answer lies in the roots of the problem.
Why are there no tractors and is Pakistan exactly because there is no private
initiative. So it's time to change the rules.
Of the gate. These buckets Buckystown to start.
Land privatization next year
Is trying to face this us forced labor sanctions whose Pakistan becomes a model
Forbes.
And now I know what you're thinking about, what you were thinking about,
what you thought before, what you thought before,
come on grind is a dictatorship as corrupt as the Uzbek one,
really going to sell off their fields transparently. And on that one,
you are absolutely right.
The privatization of Uzbek cotton is anything but squeaky clean.
And also the laws are pretty confusing.
So what they've actually done has been to seed the cultivation of the cotton
fields and then the processing of it to private entrepreneurs,
one per each region. In other words,
each of these entrepreneurs has a monopoly on cotton in their region.
And without a doubt,
the greatest beneficiary of all this privatization is a local company called
whose tanks. We are talking about the largest conglomerate and is Bekenstein.
And one that has very clear connections with the government.
This company has taken over crops from most of the regions, but to be honest,
corruption is nothing. The per is backs don't already know about. No,
at least they're starting to see farm machinery in their fields.
Listen to, it.
Was Buckystown to speed up mechanization of cotton picking.
But wait, just one woman,
if you thought that privatizing the countryside was enough to and slavery once,
and for all, you are very much mistaken.
Many of these factories are having trouble finding labor.
So think about this before. It was as simple as forcing everyone to pick cotton.
Now they have to get used to making work contracts. And in many cases,
some of these private farms are turning to local authorities to get people back
to work.
Remember that we are still talking about a dictatorship where there is no rule
of law. Even today,
many local politicians can use the police to enslave the population.
[Inaudible].
Other hunt,
independent contracted workers do not have enviable conditions either.
At the moment,
the going rate for a cotton picker is about two and a half years ID.
This is a low wage even by Uzbek standards. However,
these Pakistan of 2020 is much fairer than that of 2012. More importantly,
all of these new landowners are starting to invest in cotton pressing technology
today. 70% of the countryside of is Pakistan is already in private hands and is
starting to use agricultural machinery. But not only that,
all these new landowners,
especially those belonging to the ooze tax group are starting to invest in
cotton processing factors. In other words, in a few years,
it was Pakistan could stop exporting rock often and start selling higher value
added products, such as cotton yarn, or even a little bit.
Do you think that the Uzbek reforms are a good example for other cotton
producing countries?
Do you think the international sanctions could be more effective now again,
slave labor and gene Jang.
And do you think that I was ever wearing a t-shirt because you are mistaken,
it was always just this silk shirt, have your answer in the comments as always.
We really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos every week.
Don't forget to check out our friends. Also at the reconsider media podcast,
they provided the vocals in this episode that were not my dulcet tones. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.